and it got too overwhelming for me that
I had to take stress pills for a couple
weeks it's your choice you get to decide
how you see problems when you ask the
right questions you get a lot more
powerful answers what's that believe in
Asianet 7 my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so to help
you on your journey today we're gonna
look at the 7 ways to deal with problems
that are outside your control enjoy so I
think this is a challenge a lot of
people go through where you see a lot of
problems around you you see a lot of
negativity you see a lot of issues and
you feel like a lot of it is outside
your control so today I'm going to share
with you my seven ways on how to deal
with problems like that let's kick it
off with way number one take ownership
when you take ownership for the
situation you're more likely to start in
a positive framework I think a lot of
people default to just being upset about
it this is maybe not hopefully where you
live but where lots of people live they
live in the world of negativity they
live in the world of complaining they
live in the world of blaming other
people you are not more successful
because of whoever the president is or
whatever you know Bank is in charge you
get frustrated people get upset they
want to blame somebody else they don't
take a look in the mirror and say hey
that person's kind of blame to great
worrying when you take ownership and you
say I might be able to change something
this is my fault that I'm here I may not
have caused it I'm not the offending
party I may not be to blame for this
thing that happened but I can be a part
of the solution when you default they're
just taking that mindset taking that
thought process instead of defaulting to
complaining and blaming other people for
your situation where you're right
that's when things start to shift and
that has to be the first step the
mindset shift of taking ownership
[Music]
way number two is shifting your mindset
to think this is the best to see
problems not as problems but as
opportunities you get to decide how you
react to the world around you
Shakespeare said there is nothing
neither good or bad but thinking makes
it so
there are people who walk around and
think the world is terrible and
everything is negative and it's just
complaints and problems and these people
who walk around and think the world is
beautiful and is an amazing place to be
and America is a great country and
although the positivity that they can
think of and these two people live in
the same world sometimes they live in
the same house how does that happen it's
your choice you get to decide how you
see problems and ultimately problems
become opportunities if you can think of
it that way
that this thing that's happening to me
right now I didn't invite it I don't
want it to be here I wish it wasn't but
it came problems are coming for you and
so to think this is the best I'm gonna
use this as a chance to grow I'm gonna
use this as a chance that gets stronger
to get better to improve myself but this
is the best if you can shift your
mindset to that so the next problem that
you come across you're saying this is
the best this is my chance this is my
opportunity then you watch you're in the
right state of mind to go and solve the
problem
[Music]
way number three is ask yourself how now
we're getting dissolutions if you've
taking ownership if you've shifted the
mindset from this suck so this is the
best then you're in the right frame of
mind to ask yourself how can I solve
this problem what is the solution that
we need to do and as much as possible I
try to look at what can I personally do
not what is the country need to do what
is the teacher need to do what what is
the president of this company need to do
what can I do what can I even it's a
small way what can I do to be a part of
the solution if I can move five people
forward on this thing to get us closer
what can I do to help be a part it's
easy to come up with ideas for what
other people should do great what are
you gonna do you're upset about where
the country is going awesome don't blame
the president what are you gonna do
asking yourself that question and so
just ask yourself the how when you ask
the right questions you get a lot more
powerful answers and and this is a great
practice to get into even outside of
this topic when you are asking powerful
questions you get powerful answers
people write to me and DM me on
Instagram and they say hey Evan how long
have you been on YouTube this is the
question that you want to ask go to
socialblade and look it up anybody can
find out how long you've been on youtube
you got into my DMS I'm looking at it
that's the one question that you want to
ask ask better questions and you will
get more powerful answers when there's a
problem in front of you don't ask oh how
am I ever gonna solve this ask how am I
gonna solve this even the same words
with different intent with different
emotion will lead to more powerful
answers
[Music]
we number four is asked the parties how
ask the people who are involved in this
problem whether it's a micro problem
just with your family and they're
fighting over something going to talk to
your sister and talk to your parents and
say hey how can I be a part of the
solution just listening just trying to
broker a peace talk might be a solution
right maybe there's just a
miscommunication between people then by
you going in and understanding both
sides you can explain what's happening
if it's a much bigger problem right
something's happening in the country
then ask the parties who are involved
ask the people who are in the positions
of power ask the people who are
supporting the people in the position of
power the people who can get access to
ask them how you can be a part of the
solution get the information so that you
can make it better decision and again
default to I'm gonna make a change I'm
gonna be a part of the solution but you
may not have perfect information so
asking the people around you asking the
people involved how you can help most
people don't ever ask how they can help
most people when there's a problem or
they see somebody upset they start again
blaming other people complaining Zod's
that person's father yeah that person
shouldn't have done that how many times
when you are struggling when you are
suffering when you have a problem that
is that seems out of control somebody
comes to you and says hey I feel really
bad how can I help you that never
happens be that person for other people
see the problem and ask them how can I
help I want to serve wait number five is
model success if you don't know what to
do if you don't have the answers
hey there's good news people have
figured this helped before whatever
problem is in front of you it has been
solved before by somebody else many many
many many many times go and look it up
in a book go watching the video find the
answers on the podcast go and ask
someone who's been through it model
success the biggest mistake a lot of
people make is they think they had to
come up with every single genius idea
themselves success leaves Clues this
problem has been solved before go find
out in the many different ways that this
problem has come up and all the many
different solutions and then see how you
can apply it to your answer to your
situation the ones that have popped up
before
will get you 90% of the way
it's not a hundred percent solution you
need to customize it for yourself but it
gets you 90% of the way so why not do
that
people are so helpless a lot of times
people will so loss and it feels so
daunting or if you just realize this
problem has been solved before this is
what saved my first business how do I
sell software somebody has figured that
out before what if I just learn from
Bill Gates and apply it to my business
that got me 90% of the way that got me
into my first order that got me the
first five figure deal for my company
that was mind blowing money for me at
the time and so model and success
anytime you don't know the answer
recognize that somebody has figured this
out before and your best bet is not to
do trial and error a thousand times put
the figure out what worked tweak it to
fit your situation and then go out and
execute way number six is to be a role
model sometimes you can't help sometimes
people won't listen to your advice
sometimes people won't want you to be a
participant you know this is especially
true with family you might have had a
lot of growth over the past couple years
you might now be a growth mindset kind
of person you might be off accomplishing
big things maybe you lost a lot of
weight maybe you built the great
business and you want naturally to serve
you want your family to come alongside
with you you see your brother who's
overweight and you want him to live a
healthier lifestyle it's very rare that
that just by going up to them and saying
hey you need to be healthier I want to
help let's go but they're gonna respond
to that and I think the people closest
to you are the least likely to take your
advice because they see you as the older
version of you they still see you as the
person you were 10 years ago as opposed
to having respect for the person that
you are right now they don't respect
your opinion enough because they still
see you as that old version of you and
so the best way that I think to deal
with those situations is not direct you
can try but if they don't respond to it
trying and try and try and again like
beating them over the head you need to
get in shape you need to you need to
make more money you need to you need you
need to it's not gonna work be a role
model show them by doing
if you continue losing weight and now
you're fit and now you're happy and you
instead of rubbing it in their face or
instead of making them feel
then embracing them loving them being
around them more they will ask you you
seem so happy you've lost all this
weight like how do I get some of that
I'm a firm believer that the environment
matters that you are a product of your
environment and so if you are part of
their environment you will shift them
just because around you without you
having to be direct or tell them
anything I'm a friend believer and this
doesn't come from a legal perspective
just from a confidence perspective and
what I feel like I can accomplish
I feel like wherever I am things need to
get better just because I'm there that's
the challenge that I always set for
myself things need to get better
I think Toronto is great is hidden in
the world I think you need to get better
because I'm here and even within Toronto
Yonge and Shepherd is the intersection
of I'm at Yonge and Sheppard needs to
get better because I'm here because
otherwise what am i doing
this intersection has to get better
because I am here every room that I'm a
part of has to get better because I am
in that room and so if you take that
kind of approach and you feel confident
walking into those rooms being around
those people confident enough that you
don't get swayed by their negativity you
don't get swayed by their lack of action
because you're so strong in what you're
doing then you will pull them to you
whoever's more confident will win
instead of help sway and to help solve
problems and to help people make
progress in their lives sometimes it is
a direct over-the-top in-your-face
here's how we're gonna help here's the
plan here we go go go go and sometimes
people don't react well to that but you
can still lead them to success to the
final destination by being a positive
role model by being the person that they
want to be that they look up to and
aspire to be as opposed to you just
talking about it
[Music]
I will number seven I deal with problems
that are outside your control is don't
and let it go and that might be the
toughest of all but you can't take on
the world's problems this is something
that really struck me probably about two
years ago when I took over China dance
salsa maybe two and a half years ago I
took on everybody's problems not just
the people on my team but their family
members the sister and the husband and
the the cousin and the uncle is somebody
else on my team and it got too
overwhelming for me
that I had to take stress pills for a
couple weeks just to calm down just to
sleep just to get them off my mind and
that was not healthy and it actually
limited my ability to help because I was
taking on too much and so choosing the
fights that you want to take ownership
of choosing your battles so that you can
still stay in a happy place fulfillment
comes from doing work that is meaningful
and I think ultimately from serving
other people so you want to serve other
people you want to help them with their
problems you want to help take them from
this place to this place that that
brings immense satisfaction enjoy that's
how you get fulfillment but if you're
taking on too many people's problems you
try to help too much at once as a result
you get stressed out and break down and
you end up helping nobody and you just
hurt yourself and you drain your energy
and so part of taking ownership is
recognizing that you don't have to take
ownership over everything not everything
in the world is your problem
you can't help every single cause that's
out there you get to pick the ones that
are most meaningful for you and the ones
where you feel you can make the most
change I love helping entrepreneurs
that's that that's the flag that I have
picked up I love lots of other causes I
donate a whole bunch of other causes but
I haven't planted my flag and say this
is really important to me you know
cancer is really important to me you
know developing nations are really
important to me I think it's all
important but it's not what I'm planting
my flag in because if I tried to do
everything I wouldn't do anything and so
sometimes those big problems the ones
that are causing you stress you just
need to let go don't worry about it
it'll figure itself out it'll work out
you only do be involved because you got
other things
so those are my seven ways to deal with
problems that are outside your control I
would love to know what do you guys
think is there one that really resonate
with you is there an 8 9 10 that you
want to add to the list leave it in the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon if you tell yourself a
story long enough you start to believe
it don't you believe it you act like I
have Tulsa what a wail out of a
handcuffed lightning though Thunder in
jail now you know I'm bad over the last
week I murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between 18 and
250 four days of taking action for a new
habit to stick I've created a new course
called 250 for confidence or every
single day for 254 days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access